we begin with new developments today in
the deadly shooting death of a
three-year-old boy in the east valley
the 25 year old mother of that child
has now been arrested in the incident
this happened last night at an apartment
complex
on arlington street that's right near
charleston and nellis
metro police tell us yasmine vargas was
improperly showing off a legally
purchased gun
to a few people when it went off and hit
her child
metro's special victims units say they
are seeing too
many incidents like this and they are
urging gun owners to practice caution
we've had too many cases from everything
from cleaning a firearm
to target practice to children getting
access and playing with guns they don't
understand
and adults such as last night that are
just not familiar with the firearm how
to treat and respect the power of a
firearm
thus resulting in accidental discharges
i've been on too many
deaths too many injured people and want
everyone to hear that message and do
everything they can just a tragic
development police say there have been
three other instances like this where
people have died as a result of
mishandling a firearm
and seven other individuals where people
have been injured seven other incidents
rather we